hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt es ist endlich soweit nachdem
ihr mir ungefähr 3000 mal in die
kommentare geschrieben habe dass ihr die
spaghetti tacos von icarly haben wollt
bekommt ihr heute die spaghetti tacos
von sowie hannover
das rezept ist so einfach dass es selbst
david haye hinkriegen würde versprochen
für spaghetti tacos brauchen wie attac
schal nudeln und zwar die strecke die
nudeln allerfeinste selbstgemachter
tomatensoße und natürlich
fleischbällchen die veganen die könnt
natürlich auch echte fleischbällchen
nehmen aber ganz ehrlich wollt ihr das
wollt ihr das wirklich als erstes nehmen
wir uns einen topf und dann machen wir
die soße auf jetzt kommt die soße noch
in den topf fertig und jetzt kommt ganz
wichtig die lupe leute ich muss einfach
nicht wie man spaghetti mit soße macht
na das ist ja wohl gerade recht
wir nehmen jetzt uns einen großen topf
und fühlenden wasser rein
jetzt nehmen wir ein bisschen salz und
setzen unser wasser das gute tafelsalz
das watt kommt der presse
jetzt nehmen wir den topf mit dem wasser
und dem seite und werden das aufkochen
und ich hoffe dass ich ein
induktionsherd auch verdienen kann dann
power to power
jetzt bin ich echt gespannt wie schnell
das geht während das wasser noch
aufkocht können wir ja mal über
nickelodeon serien sprechen was habt ihr
denn sonst außer alkali gesehen
ich habe noch so johannes angeschaut bis
ich herausgefunden habe dass sie so wie
die schwester von britney spears ist
dann fand ich so über nacht nicht mehr
cool ich weiß auch nicht genau wie so
eine antihaltung gegen britney spears
und dann war auch ihre schwester leider
durch für mich und reck und josh das hat
mir noch richtig gerne angebot war so
ein bisschen verliebt im drake ist
geguckt beratet mir woche
ich dachte du wärst wird platte jetzt wo
das wasser kocht muss mir die nudel
hinzufügen was für eine überraschung
und sie sind alle was war ich werd
verrückt so die nudeln müssen jetzt für
zehn minuten kochen und in der tat
manchmal die soße wahr machen will
unbedingt wissen wie diese takko schalen
aussehen nicht dass auch ein spaghetti
takko sofort gelb oder sie super
künstlich aus wir probieren jetzt
zusammen so ein hackbällchen okay bei
dem bereit für ein veganes
fleischbällchen black pack die
fleischbällchen ist einfach mit in die
soße
fertig jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich ein
see gefunden und jetzt muss ich die
holen jetzt haben wir ein topf nudeln
und da machen jetzt noch die soße rhein
ihr sagt dass es ein haufen nudeln mit
hackbällchen ich sage mutiert gekocht
jetzt müssen wir alles gut miteinander
verrühren
ich weiß nicht warum ich eine ganze
packung nudeln genommen habe wir haben
jetzt einfach mal drei kilo nudeln mit
sechs hackbällchen körper messer gezückt
und jetzt kommt der allerwichtigste und
letzte schritt wir nehmen uns einen
takko und ein paar hat welche jetzt habe
ich das werk welchem rein gemacht und
jetzt nehmen wir uns eine schöne große
portion nudeln machen da rein und fertig
ist unser spektakel
und jetzt stellen uns natürlich wieder
der wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt's
tier ist ne guten appetit
echt sowas bitte nicht beim ersten date
es geht überhaupt nicht ein großes
wissen für mama die spaghetti tacos aus
kali schmecken sehr gut
ich habe aber ganz ehrlich auch nichts
anderes erwartet weil kennt die auf
diese pizza pasta diese pizza mit nudeln
obendrauf die finde ich auch extrem
lecker und deswegen google schmeckt
immer super ich auch mal nudeln auf brot
gegessen eine zeit lang wie gesagt es
dieses zeug mich beim ersten date ich
hoffe natürlich hat wie immer die folge
gefallen und wenn ja dann zeigt es mir
mit einem daumen nach oben und wenn ihr
anderes rezept vorschläge habt oder
sachen die nachkochen soll schreibt sie
unten in die kommentare
und irgendwann werde ich sie auch mal
nachgucken ganz sicher
[Musik]
bis dann